the smoke from the blast descends across
the departure hall in a deadly clouds
these pictures were taken seconds after
the suicide bombers struck people cower
on the floor everywhere there's
uncertainty and fear as the injured
stumble in the gloom trying to reach
safety around the bodies and debris from
the blast the fear is that more
explosions are about to come
luggage lies abandoned as many people
run for their lives
[Music]
it felt close it wasn't just a question
of hearing the sound we felt the sound
we felt the shockwaves of those
explosions so we were pretty close
another indication is that we saw the
sort of dust come from the ceiling and
the shelves in the shop we're in the
bottles juddered
we just passed through security when we
heard the explosions we were waiting to
board a flight to Tel Aviv around us
terrified passengers flee but they're
unsure about where to turn bang
everybody right and came along here you
saw kind of smoke you know so the the
shopkeeper windows it's oh no it's not
it's nothing urgent because you're
working in here it was very loud
explosion yes it was very loud yes it
was not something that fell on the
ground you know or something like free
yes very frightening yes
others speak to their loved ones on the
phone telling them they're safe many
people just stare blankly traumatized
whilst children hope for reassurance
eventually the authorities managed to
evacuate the building on the tarmac
outside the victims shiver with cold and
shock many of them wrapped in blankets
to keep warm first thing is get people a
farm up and go to secure area so as soon
as you can
if you can't woman and children first
before the buses Andrew and Denise
Brandt told me they were about to fly to
Asia when they heard and felt the blasts
how far do you think you were from the
explosion you know I don't know don't
muffled so I knew we were not very close
to it but we were close enough that it
reverberating throughout our entire
bodies so
I don't know how this would have
happened in class they said happen in
check-in there's a woman with a baby in
our arms and she told me I have a second
baby where is this was the softest of
targets a major airport in a European
city it was busy with business people
and families about to start their
journeys we heard the explosions less
than an hour ago two very loud blasts we
were in the duty-free we'd been through
security at this time the walls of the
building shook there was dust coming
from the ceiling we saw people running
towards us great deal of confusion and
chaos one woman had blood streaming down
her face the airport itself has now been
evacuated and people have been people
have been told they're being taken to a
crisis center it's now emerged the
Belgian intelligence services knew and
attack was imminent
but the wouldn't be just one as we were
being taken out of the airport the
terrorists strike again this time the
target is a metro station close to the
European Union's main institution in the
darkness below ground children's screams
fill the tunnel this is what terror is
[Applause]
the number of dead would continue to
rise throughout the day
the injured were treated on the
pavements or wherever they leg
back at the airport it was still unclear
whether the attacks were over people
attended to the wounded as the army and
the police moved in the federal
prosecutor has now released an image of
three of the suspects the men on the
left
dressed in black are thought to be the
suicide attackers the man and whites
wearing a hat is still at large and
described as extremely dangerous the
country's Prime Minister Charles Michel
said what they had been fearing for so
long was now a reality the big commander
for us there is of course at the fore
and an after
we are very shocked by the information
and the witness statements we heard as
well as the images we saw these images
will remain engraved in our memories
there are of course many unanswered
questions about the attacks how many
terrorists were involved and how many
others are still at large
Brussels is a place consumed by fear
Alex Rossi Sky News is a vente airport